les enjeux tels que les ont énoncés
c'est avant tout de garantir la sécurité
mondiale il s'agit d'une sécurité
alimentaire pour les pays du Sud qu'il a
mentionné c'est évidemment aussi une
sécurité que l'Ukraine souhaite dans
l'Ukraine souhaite pouvoir bénéficier
elle-même une sécurité territoriale
alors ce qui est intéressant dans cette
réunion on l'a mentionné c'est qu'il ne
va pas seulement y avoir les alliés
traditionnels de l'Ukraine je pense
notamment à l'Union européenne il va
également y avoir des représentants de
pays qui ont la mentionné jusqu'à
présent ne sont jusqu'à présent pas
forcément exprimés sur leur position
vis-à-vis de cette guerre ou alors ont
été plutôt ambiguës et ce sont des pays
dont le soutien est crucial et
primordial pour pour l'Ukraine je pense
à la Chine je pense à l'Inde je pense au
pays du Sud justement ça c'est un
premier point le deuxième point c'est
que la Russie n'est pas invité à la
table
discussion le troisième point c'est que
c'est le plan de paix tel qu'il est
établi par Kiev qui va être discuté donc
sécurité alimentaire moyen de de lutter
contre un écosside par exemple on sait
que ça ça n'a pas encore été implémenté
on a vu l'explosion du barrage de
karovka il y a il y a deux mois elle est
conséquences désastreuses pour
l'environnement c'est conséquences elles
concernent le monde entier pas seulement
l'Ukraine et puis en s'assurant le
soutien de nouveaux alliés et bien Kiev
entend mettre en place en fait sa propre
sécurité comme je le mentionnais dans ce
plan de paix pour qui il y a la
restauration de l'intégrité territoriale
de l'Ukraine c'est-à-dire plus les
régions de deniers et de Louane ce qui
sont qui sont occupés ou en partie
occupés depuis 2014 plus le retour de la
Crimée également occupé illégalement
depuis 2014 ce sont tous ces points qui
seront discutés aujourd'hui